president Trump's insisted that he bears
no responsibility for any spike in the
number of people misusing disinfectant
last week mr. Trump was strongly
criticized by doctors for suggesting
that ingesting disinfectants might be a
potential coronavirus cure our us
correspond equivalence joins us now from
Washington could Elia welcome to you mr.
Trump insists his remarks were sarcastic
yes absolutely he suggested that last
week after there was a lot of
incredulity and condemnation at those
remarks when as you say he touted this
idea that ingesting or injecting
disinfectant could in some way help
people to battle coronavirus of course
scientists and many state officials were
pretty quick to say that that is not the
case that it would be hugely dangerous
if any of their constituents were to do
that since Donald Trump's suggestion
there was a pretty Swift spike in the
number of phone calls to poison control
centers across the United States with
some particular States saying they had
had double the number of calls related
to people ingesting something called
Lysol it's the American equivalent of
Dettol making inquiries as well about
industrial bleach that caused a lot of
alarm and so state officials felt they
needed to correct the record one of the
states where this was an issue is
Maryland which borders District of
Columbia where I am at the moment in the
governor Larry Hogan they're making sure
that everyone knew that it was not safe
of course to ingest disinfectant Donald
Trump was asked about that yesterday in
the Rose Garden governor Larry Hogan
specifically said they've seen a spike
in people using disinfectant after your
comments last week I know you said they
were sorry I can't imagine why I can't
imagine why yeah any responsibility I
can't imagine I can't imagine that yeah
go ahead please
see is he Donald Trump you know refusing
really to engage in this issue and
certainly not accepting any
responsibility what he wanted to talk
about yesterday was a new rollout of
testing across the United States the
government's aim is to get 2% of the
populations in each state tested but it
must be said the responsibility in the
financing from that will often come from
those states rather than federal
government they want people to pursue
their own paths and that's the case
calling for opening up as well we're
going to see places like Texas this
Friday start their phase of beginning to
reopen Donald Trump welcoming Matt on
Twitter today he's also been showing his
support for protesters talking about
liberating places like at Michigan and
Minnesota - and I think that is the
dynamic that's quite unique to America
that we're going to see play out and
lots of potential tensions along the way
this is a federal system American
individualism certainly on show here and
I think people have learned that they
need to make their own choices rather
than relying on central government
cordelia thanks a lot